Welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof. I'm Walter. I'm Martin.
Are you doing well?
I'm shorn like a lamb.
And now the wind has not been tempered
so I'm freezing.
Yeah, and
crazy we
one day we have 38°
C
the next day it's 10° C.
Yes. Probably climate change. It's
called global cooling. Oh, okay.
Well, we've got very important message
today again.
It's part of the most important messages
to to be taken to the world. Yes.
So, let's pray and ask the Lord to help
us.
We need prayer.
Heavenly Father, thank you that we have
the opportunity to discuss this
wonderful message again today. We ask
that you enlighten our minds, guide us
with the Holy Spirit, and protect us
with your holy angels. In Jesus' name,
amen. Amen.
Martin, it's possible that people will
take offense
as to what we will be saying.
But a serious study will show that it is
actually a help. Mhm.
So, that people can discern between the
various options out there.
And discernment is the name of the game.
Be careful lest anyone deceive you. The
first words that we read
that the Lord says in the book of
Revelation.
Yes.
So, we're going to talk about the second
angel today.
And it's only one verse
in the whole Bible that we're talking
about.
So, it will it's it will be a short
discussion. It'll be a very short
discussion. The trouble with this verse
is you don't know what to leave out.
The problem is not what to put in, but
what to leave out.
Because this is a very loaded verse.
And it doesn't isn't a standalone verse.
No.
Because this message is repeated in
Revelation chapter 18.
So, we have to split the information.
Yes. So, we cannot put everything into
one verse. We have to put it into the
greater context later of Revelation 18.
So, we will be looking at some basic
things and that's a problem already.
But let's see how far we can go.
Let's hope that we can finish under
4 or 5 hours, right?
Revelation 14:8.
And there followed another angel saying,
"Babylon is fallen,
is fallen, that great city, because she
made all the nations drink of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication."
Martin, that's a very loaded verse.
Mhm.
And there are a number of features in it
that are important.
There is this message of Babylon is
fallen and it's repeated. Mhm. That's
number one.
And why has she fallen? Because she made
the nations drink of the wine. That's
doctrine
of the wrath of her fornication, her
apostasy.
So, apostate doctrines from Babylon have
been transferred into the thinking
pattern of humanity, the nations,
which includes the churches.
Now, once the nations start thinking
like the churches think, then church and
state working together could become
problematic, right?
True. Yes. I'm interested to see that
the new speaker of the house said he has
a problem with the separation of church
and state. He wants them to be together.
Yeah.
That's a fulfillment of prophecy.
That's pendulum swinging getting to
where
prophecy will be fulfilled.
Correct. But let's see why. Mhm.
And this is very important. So, we want
to know a few things.
Now, we've spoken about these many in
many lectures, but so that people can
have one reference point, let's just
repeat some things.
We need to know who is Babylon. Yeah.
We need to know why the message that it
has fallen is being repeated.
Mhm.
We need to know what the wine is. Yes.
And we need to know how to influence the
nations. That's it.
Right? And it's a great city. Mhm.
So, let's jump right into it.
There was a literal fall of Babylon and
obviously this is now a spiritual fall
because literal Babylon no longer
exists, right?
Exactly. Fall.
Fell.
So, let's look at the original. Daniel
5:25.
This is the writing that was written
when the hand appeared and wrote against
the wall, right?
Mhm. And it said, "Mene, mene, tekel,
upharsin." Now, there's also a
repetition there. Mene, mene is
repeated, right?
This is the interpretation of the thing.
Mene,
"God has numbered thy kingdom and
finished it."
So, basically it says God has numbered
thy kingdom and finished it. God has
numbered thy thy
kingdom and finished it.
So, historically we have to look at why
there are two components.
Now, in the time that this was written,
Belshazzar was the king who ruled over
secular issues.
Mhm. But his father was the real king.
Yes. And he ruled over the spiritual
issues. So, there was a spiritual
component and a secular component and
they were united. Yes. Let's say church
and state was together. Together ruling.
It is one of the components of Babylon
Mhm.
that the state will ensure that the
religious components of Babylon are also
adhered to. That's it. That is why King
Nebuchadnezzar, when he took the
captives to Babylon, he made sure that
they learn everything about the
Babylonian religion. He even changed
their names to reflect the Babylonian
religion.
Yeah.
So, we need to remember that.
Tekel, thou art weighed in the balances
and art found wanting and peres, thy
kingdom is divided and given to the
Medes and Persians.
So, Babylon was conquered.
And that was the typical
destruction.
Yeah, the literal.
The literal.
So, there's an antitypical one that
we're talking about now. So, we need to
know what the attributes were of
Babylon.
Mhm.
Now, where did Babylon start? Yeah. We
have to go way back into history. So, we
go back to Genesis
chapter 11:9.
All right, so we have to go back to the
survivors of the flood. Yes. They had
increased in numbers.
Mhm.
And then they started to build the city
and they built the Etemenanki, the Tower
of Babel. Mhm. Now, why did they build
it, Martin?
Because they did not believe what God
said.
God said he would not destroy the world
by a flood again.
Mhm.
And they
disbelieved God. Mhm.
And so they decided to build this tower
so that he would no longer be able to
destroy them with the flood. Yes. It was
to reach right up to heaven, right?
Mhm.
So, it's a system based on a disbelief
in the word of God.
Yeah.
And it's a system of we will take care
of ourselves.
Now, the builder of the city
and the power that ruled over it was
Nimrod. Yes. And he was a a warrior
before the Lord.
Yeah.
But he was a warrior actually against
the Lord.
That's it. His name means rebel.
Right? So, here was this rebel.
And he was the grandson of Ham. Yeah.
Now, Ham obviously had
esoteric knowledge. Mhm. Knowledge of
rebellion. Because you see his
rebellious nature right from the
beginning and we've dealt with what he
did and how it was exposed
and how the curse trickled down via
Canaan and Nimrod was the one who again
officially reinstated this rebellion
against God.
And the whole religion of Babylon
revolves around the legends that took
place.
Of course, they trace themselves back to
before the flood.
Yes.
And this religion emanates from Cain.
Mhm.
And Cain made his son Yes.
the custodian of his thinking patterns.
Mhm. And his son, of course, was Enoch.
Enoch. Not the good Enoch. Let's not
confuse him. Mhm. Enoch, son of Cain, is
the first one to build a city.
And that's why it's called a city.
Yeah, they were city builders.
They were city builders, but the city
Mhm. stands for
global governance. We will rule the
entire world.
Mhm.
Now, God stopped their little plan by
confusing their languages.
And it says in Genesis 11:9, therefore
is the name of it called Babel.
Because the Lord did there confound the
language of all the earth, and from
thence that the Lord scattered them
abroad upon the face of all the earth.
So, all of a sudden they spoke different
languages, and they could no longer
communicate, and then you had the
different nations.
Yes. That was to prevent a unified
world government.
Yeah.
Are we striving towards one? A United
Nations. How many years have they been
striving for that? Millennia. From the
beginning. From the day that they were
confounded, they have been striving to
get unity.
And this must have been a major problem,
right? For sure. And they couldn't
understand each other anymore.
So, within the secret echelons, they
then decided to come up with a plan.
Mhm.
And this plan was to no longer use
language per se to communicate whatever
their secret doctrine was,
Yeah.
but to use symbols.
And signs.
So, that it couldn't be confused any
longer, because anybody can look at it
and make a conclusion.
And if you were an initiate, then you
could understand. So, this is actually a
religion of rebellion against God,
disbelieving God, relying on humanity to
take care of its own future, yeah,
excluding God. That's Babylon.
But it is a religious organization.
Powered by government.
Yes, so it's a mindset. It's a mindset.
a religious mindset, and it's not the
mindset of God.
No, it's not the mindset of God. So,
here is a is a depiction of the origin
of secret societies in the world. And
this comes from Gary H. Kah's book on
route to global occupation. In other
words, they want a world government,
right? How do you achieve this? Because
you have to work underground
to overcome the surface opposition.
Let's put it that way.
Okay, exactly. So, there's a special
know behind the scenes that they know,
and the rest is in the dark.
Correct. And of course, it's very
important, Martin, that the the
conditions which exist in any particular
population or any language group
be diluted.
So, let's say you have a nation and they
speak French.
Then you have to make sure that many
different cultures and languages come
into that culture. So, that it isn't one
culture that dominates, but all, and
they have to somehow compromise.
Yes. So, you have to bring migrants into
countries like France or Germany or
Italy or Greece or
wherever. You have to get the migrants
in there so that you can change the
collective mindset so that you can get
global occupation. You have to get
compromise.
Yes.
Now, compromise politically is one
thing.
Mhm. But compromise religiously is
totally a different kettle of fish.
In in Christianity, in the doctrine of
Jesus being the only way to heaven, you
cannot compromise.
That's a that's a major obstacle. That
has to go.
So, the ancient mystery religions ought
to be used in order to get back to the
Babylon state.
Where everybody is one and has the same
mindset.
Yeah. But that mindset is a mindset of
rebellion.
That's it.
Okay.
So, you have the ancient mystery
religions of Babylon, Egypt, India,
Persia, Greece, and they were all forms
of pantheism.
Do we find pantheism in the papal
encyclicals?
Yes, very much so.
All right.
Then you had cabalism.
Mhm.
Now, cabalism is a mystic religion.
Now, much of Judaism today is based on
cabalism.
And the other religions as well,
actually, the whole occult world traces
itself back to the cabal.
Mhm.
And then you had gnosticism.
Gnosticism is where man is deified.
Yeah. So, you
you must believe in yourself, because
you can be God. Trust your heart,
Martin.
Mhm.
But the heart is
deceivable. And it's above all things.
And it's
desperately wicked.
So, how do you want to trust it? Anyway,
gnosticism was a great preparatory
movement.
Mhm. And it was particularly prevalent
in the time after Christ.
Yes. And some of the gnostics were very,
very busy when it came to biblical
manuscripts. Like Origen, for example.
He was a gnostic.
Yeah. And his one of his disciples of or
followers was Eusebius.
Mhm.
And he was a bishop that was very
favorably inclined to and a flatterer of
Constantine.
Mhm.
And certain changes were made, which
were sanctioned by the gnostics,
which which were sanctioned by the
gnostics, but should be refuted
with every power of your being if you
were a Bible believer. Changes, you
mean? Changes in the scriptures? Changes
to biblical manuscripts, and then you
have, of course, the flagship
manuscripts on which modern Bibles are
based, for example, the Sinaiticus and
the Vaticanus. They were probably
contaminated by gnosticism.
And then you had the Knights Templars.
Now, that is a particularly interesting
organization that is tightly linked to
Catholicism.
Mhm.
And it was the military arm, the one to
take the message, the wine, to the
entire world.
That's why they used crusades. Yes. Now,
the Knights Templars were disbanded,
but the the descendants are very, very
active.
Mhm. So, today the descendants of the
Knights Templars would be the Knights of
Malta,
the secret organizations within
Catholicism, and the Jesuits, of course.
And then you had Rosicrucianism,
which was basically alchemism.
It is a
the secret of the occult science.
Mhm. Studied in diagrams, etc., and
symbols.
And out of that, you had Freemasonry and
the Illuminati. Mhm. Now, the Illuminati
was founded by Adam Weishaupt, who was a
Jesuit.
Yes.
And Freemasonry is based on this ancient
occult religious system. If people want
to know more, they can look at the
secret behind secret societies, for
example, in the Tørlands Law series.
All right. Now, Freemasonry
infiltrated
the echelons of politics and religion.
Mhm. So, if you look at many of the
great religious leaders of the last
centuries, they were all Freemasons.
Yeah. Whether they came from the
Protestant world or another world.
That's it.
The Islamic world has Masonic lodges.
The Jewish lodges.
Christian lodges, so-called.
Yeah.
They infiltrated organizations such as
the World Council of Churches, the
international banking elite, the
American and European secret political
societies, and Marxism.
Mhm. So, they're playing a nice Hegelian
game.
Yeah. It's the same with um
your revolutions, tyrants, and war of
the Then you can see all the kings of
the earth or the presidents, they're all
the same. They're part of the
Freemasonry, so they're sitting behind
closed doors at the same table.
Correct. So, all of this comes from
Babylon.
Yeah.
And this is the way in which you're
going to achieve world governance.
Yeah. You have to create unity of
thought in the political realm,
or at least tolerance.
And you have to create unity of thought
in the religious realm, or at least
tolerance.
That means there can be no exclusivity.
Yeah.
So, you cannot say one religion is the
only way because that would exclude the
others. That wouldn't be unity.
All right. And that gave rise to the New
Age movement, which is heavily
influenced by the Theosophical
societies.
And the Theosophical societies are the
straightforward worship of Lucifer.
And then you have many of the cults of
the 1800s that are involved over there.
So, here in the New Age, you have new
spiritual technology, you have
self-hypnosis, you have subliminal
persuasions, you have neuro-linguistic
programming, you have all of these
issues to change mindsets.
And from the ancient religions, you have
anything from witchcraft, sorcery,
divination, spiritism,
all of these things. And some of the
practices of Hinduism, Buddhism,
Shintoism, etc.
All of this is part of Babylon. It's all
part of Babylon.
It's the power under the surface.
You're supposed to know about it, but
not to understand it unless you are an
initiate.
Yeah. Or unless you've studied it.
So, let's get a few quotes just to get
put the background. Morals and Dogma is
of course the highest source in
Freemasonry. You don't get a better
source than this by Albert Pike.
He says, "Every Masonic lodge is a
temple of religion."
That puts it beyond doubt. It's a
religious organization.
And its teachings are instruction in
religion.
"This is the true religion revealed to
the ancient patriarchs, which Masonry
has taught for many centuries,
and which will continue to teach as long
as time endures."
Now, the patriarchs that they refer to
are not the patriarchs of the Bible.
They are eyewash.
They are referring to their initiates,
Enoch, son of Cain, Nimrod.
That's what they are referring to. They
literally refer to the Tower of Babel as
their structure.
They are building the Tower of Babel.
That's why they are the they've got the
set compass and square because they are
builders of cities. The correct. And if
you take the emblem of the the new
Europe, you'll see that it is the Tower
of Babel under construction. Yeah. Even
like you showed in that one that the
Washington DC the outlet outlay of the
city is Masonic. Yes, correct.
All right. Here's another Masonic
source, Manly P. Hall, The Lost Keys of
Freemasonry. The true Mason is not creed
bound.
"He realizes with the divine
illumination of his lodge that as a
Mason, his religion must be universal."
That's a very key issue.
"Christ, Buddha, or Muhammad, the name
means little for he recognizes only the
light and not the bearer.
He worships at every shrine, bows before
every altar, whether in temple, mosque,
or cathedral,
realizing with his truer understanding
the oneness of all spiritual truth."
So, there goes absolute truth. That's
it. So, it's
it's hypocritical. He's behind he can
show something, but he's what he
believes is actually the opposite.
Something totally different. And the
true light bearer cannot be Christ
because he cannot be the only way. He
cannot be Buddha, and it cannot be
Muhammad. So, it must be someone else,
and that someone else they blatantly
admit is Lucifer.
So, it's a system of works
against God.
So, you have to become all things to all
men.
So, Martin, if we look at the papacy,
then we see that they are all things to
all men.
For example, here are two pictures of
Pope John Paul II being anointed with
the sign of the tilak,
which basically means that he's prepared
to embrace the gods of the Hindus.
And kissing the Quran, which basically
means that he is embracing or showing
reverence for its teachings. Yes.
But it denies the atonement.
Yes. It denies the sonship of Christ.
There's no compromise. There's no
gelling of these religions with
Christianity.
Nothing. So, this is a compromise that
excludes Jesus Christ.
And it's a breaking of the first
command. And you shall have no other
gods beside me. Definitely. Pope Francis
had the Amazon
idols there in the Vatican that was
blessed by him. So, he's no different.
It's right through this time. It's a
theme.
It's the construction of the city.
And the city is Babylon.
But the city's location can be in a
different place, right?
And then of course you have Francesco
Fratelli Tutti,
all brothers.
Now, the Bible talks about neighbors.
All are your neighbors.
But brothers is something else.
When Jesus was told that his mother and
his brothers and his sisters were
waiting outside, his answer was,
"For whosoever shall do the will of my
father which is in heaven, the same is
my brother and sister and mother." So,
it's a very specific criteria. So, who
is my brother in Christ? The one who
does the will of the father.
And didn't the father say, "This is my
beloved son, hear him?" Yes.
So, if you don't adhere to the teachings
of Christ, then you're not a brother.
Unfortunately. Then you might be a
neighbor, and I must love my neighbor as
myself, and I must be kind to my
neighbor and not wish him any harm,
but he's definitely you're not a brother
in the faith.
So, when he writes
all brothers, Fratelli Tutti,
that's a Babylonian concept.
Yeah.
So, the Catechism of the Catholic Church
actually teaches, "For the Son of God
became man so that we might become God.
The only begotten Son of God wanting to
make us share us in his divinity assumed
our nature
so that he made man might make men
gods."
That's incredible, Martin. Yeah. That is
echoing the teaching of the serpent.
Yes, to Eve.
And here's another quote from the
Catechism, "Marvel and rejoice, we have
become Christ." That's a New Age concept
that we can become Christ.
There's a book by Helen Schucman, which
is called A Course in Miracles, which
basically teaches that you can become
Christ or even much more than he was.
So, this is a blasphemous statement.
And it is part of the Babylonian
concept. Of course, Babylon also had
mother and child worship.
And there were different deities with
different names, female and male, which
were invoked. And Catholicism has the
same by invocation of the saints and
Mary.
Let's see if we can find the same
teaching in Masonry, right?
Manly P. Hall, 33rd degree Mason, "Man
is a god in the making."
George Steinmetz, a Masonic writer,
writes, "Be still and know that I am
God, that I am God, the final
recognition of the all in all, the unity
of the self with the cosmos, the
cognition of the divinity of the self."
It's exactly the same religion.
And uh
J.D. Buck, Mystic Masonry, writes, "The
perfect man is Christ, and Christ is
God. This is the birthright and destiny
of every human soul."
This is the teaching of the United
Nations.
This is where the Jesuits were involved.
Pierre Teilhard de Chardin, he was
basically the father of the New Age
movement.
The the Blavatskys and the Alice A.
Baileys, they are embraced by these
organizations. It's a Babylonian system.
Yeah.
That whole system, I mean, there was
even pictures I remember of the United
Nations that is as a form of the Tower
of Babel. Absolutely. And the
interesting thing is
they teach that we are this brotherhood
here and that we must make our home on
this earth.
Yeah. This earth is the place where you
receive your salvation, not something
outside of you
and going to another place.
So, let's see if we can find this in the
Jesuitical teaching. Yes, we've shown
this slide before, but I think it fits.
This is Paul Natter, he's of course a
Jesuit theologian.
"For Jesus, the spirit-filled prophet,
that's already a blasphemy. I can hardly
read this stuff.
The focus of his life and the
relationship was the reign of God. That
meant that he was not, as his followers
have often been, church-centered.
His primary concern was not to increase
membership of his own movement or
community, rather it was to transform
people's hearts so as to transform their
society.
He actually writes the following,
"That's it. That's the crux of the
problem. Christian dualism has so
exaggerated the difference between God
and the world that it cannot really show
how the two form a unity." So, he's
breaking down what God said.
Yeah. God said, "Love of the world is
enmity
with God, right?" And he changes it. He
goes further and writes, "Without
Buddha, I could not be a Christian."
Now, Buddha is basically the negation of
God. It's an atheistic religion.
But the scriptures say, "Ye adulterers
and adulteresses, know ye not that
friendship of the world is enmity with
God?
Whosoever therefore will be a friend of
the world is the enemy of God."
So, when the Babylonian system tries to
rebuild that Tower of Babel,
it is a humanist
it's a works-based one.
It's a works-based one, and when it
comes into a religious system, then you
have to beware of it.
Because either the Bible is right and
there's only one way to salvation
or it is not right, and then you have
the Luciferian side.
Let's see how far they go.
Morals and Dogma again, Albert Pike, the
top source in Masonry. Masonry, like all
the religions, all the mysteries,
hermeticism and alchemy, conceals its
secrets from all except the adepts and
sages
or the elect and uses false explanations
and misinterpretations
of its symbols to mislead those who
deserve only to be misled.
That already
is a statement that negates every Bible
principle. Definitely. Jesus said, "I
did nothing in secret." This whole thing
is based on secrecy.
It's based on secrecy, so it is a
Babylonian system.
To conceal the truth, which it calls
light, from them and to draw them away
from it. Truth is not for those who are
unworthy or unable to receive it.
Does the Bible teach something like
that?
No, not at all. Doesn't. The Bible says
the word is truth, so the whole word is
truth and it's available to everybody.
All right, because they say
they would pervert it.
So, Masonry jealously conceals its
secrets and intentionally leads
conceited interpreters astray.
You are intentionally led astray by the
Babylonian system.
If you read this, then you understand
why in the Middle Ages the papacy banned
the Bible. Yes. Here's another statement
from Blavatsky. She's the top occultist,
prophet, if you like.
"Lucifer represents life, thought,
progress, civilization, liberty,
independence. Lucifer is the logos, the
serpent, the savior."
So, there's a reversal. Lucifer becomes
the Christ, the word, the logos. His
word counts.
And true Christianity is negated.
To put it bluntly, she writes, "It is
Satan who is the God of our planet and
the only God." So, they are Luciferian.
Now, let's not get confused here.
Luciferian
or Satanist,
it's basically one in the same thing.
Mhm. Lucifer is the light side.
Yes.
Satan is the dark side. It's a yin-yang
situation. So, whether you worship from
the one angle or the other angle makes
no difference to these people. We'll see
how this works.
Here's another quote from another
Masonic source. "The symbols came to
have two meanings." Remember that the
Babylonian founders decided to put
everything into symbols.
Yes, to because of the language. And
then the initiates would understand, but
the non-initiated would not, and God
would not be able to confuse them
anymore.
They really underestimate God.
Right?
Because they could be looking at
something and it could be something
totally different if God wanted to
change it.
Yeah.
But nevertheless, they always
underestimate God.
So, there are two meanings, the esoteric
and the exoteric. The esoteric is what
they call the real meaning. That's for
the inner
For the inner circle. And the exoteric
is for the for the public out
there.
So, the esoteric meaning was the true
original meaning understood by only a
few and closely guarded by them. The
exoteric meaning was invented or
modified explanation intended for the
many.
The sacred mysteries, which are often
mentioned in connection with many
ancient religions and which were closely
guarded by the initiate, concerned
esoteric meanings in the religions of
previous times. So, when you read Christ
in the Bible, they read Lucifer. Yeah.
When they read the word logos, they
understand Lucifer.
These sacred mysteries very often were
merely continuations of the simpler
forms of early sex worship carried on by
a select few.
Modern, that gives you a clue as to why
the world is so sexually perverse.
Yeah.
And not only in terms of the Hollywood
aspect,
Yeah.
but right through even to the religious
aspects. And Masonry in particular has
some very
sinister little activities, which we
won't talk about.
So, let me give an example of how the
esoteric and exoteric
is portrayed in their symbols.
All right. Let's look at the Templars.
Templars are basically the driving force
of the political religious unification
within Catholicism
that is taken to every sphere of life.
Okay, so it's a militant part of the
church-state entity. Yes. So, you'll
have the Knights of Malta in many, many
organizations.
And of course, the Jesuits, which are
basically the general and the top
echelon of the whole system.
So, in the book Morals and Dogma, again,
the top Masonic source, it says, "The
Templars, like all other secret orders
and associations, had two doctrines, one
concealed and reserved for the masters,
which was Johannism,
and the other public, which was the
Roman Catholic."
Now, when it comes to Johannism, that's
a very interesting concept. You might
know you have the Cathedral of St. John
the Divine.
Yeah. The name already is a blasphemy.
St. John the Divine, St. John wasn't
divine.
No, but he
gives him godly status.
It gives him godly status, and what goes
on in that cathedral is beyond words,
right? Now, they love to uh use John the
Baptist
as a front, as a symbol.
But there are two sides to that story.
Remember he was beheaded?
Yeah. For his faith, for which he stood.
And they actually celebrate that
beheading because they are on the side
of Lucifer. Who initiated the beheading?
Lucifer. Yeah, using Herodias, right?
And Salome.
It was actually church and state. Yes,
and Herodias, of course, stands for the
mother church, and the daughter would be
the daughter church. So, they would also
want to behead the antitypical John the
Baptist.
The other one that they love to revere
is St. Paul.
Wasn't he also beheaded?
Yes. Who initiated that beheading?
Also Lucifer. So, when they use it, they
use it as a symbol of victory over the
truth.
Yeah.
So, Modern, I took these pictures that
we see over here at one of those huge
Catholic enclaves with a massive
cathedral-like churches as well. In that
place where church leaders and state
leaders come together to discuss issues
of mutual interest. And in this place,
they have a statue here which they call
David. Mhm.
And they say this is David taking care
of the sheep. So, David is the good
shepherd over here.
But if you look, this is the exoteric
doctrine.
For the for the
For the They say that this is
David. But if you look at David over
here,
he's got a pan flute in his hand.
David never played the pan
He played the harp. Yeah. Which was the
hand harp, right?
So, this is actually a depiction of the
god Pan. Yes. And this is the light side
of the god Pan, the good side, the good
shepherd side. So, this is the Lucifer
side.
So, when I saw this and I saw the pan
flute in his hand, I knew that this was
the god Pan
in his light side. So, somewhere they
must depict him in his evil side as
well. So, I went looking around and I
found the pillars and lo and behold,
there you have the god Pan in his evil
goat form, half man, half goat.
So, this is yin yang. Yeah. And to put
it beyond the doubt, they have Janus,
the two-headed one up there,
which is also the yin yang. So, you have
the light side and your dark side. You
have
light magic and you have dark magic.
White magic.
White magic, yes.
Well, and then
White magic and black magic.
That's it. And then as you put it, this
is the esoteric and exoteric Yes.
meeting because the exoteric is
portraying him as David, but the
esoteric
he is
the god Pan. Yes, and this is of course
just art, nothing else.
But if you look at the renovations that
take place, there's a big sign outside,
the renovator is Masonic because he has
the Masonic symbol on his board. Now, he
could sell all that, but you know, it's
long time in the making. Let's take
another example.
This is what's in Paul's Cathedral,
which is a Protestant in club. You know,
the one where
the king is coronated. And King Charles
was just coronated there.
And this is what it looked like in the
old days.
This is a model that you find in the
place.
And it was reconstructed to look like
this.
Now, this reconstruction
is a copy of the Vatican. Yeah.
Martin, this is an image of the Vatican.
That's it. And then if you go and look,
the capital
of
uh the United States
is similar to this again. It's based on
it. They are an image of the beast, the
beast being Catholicism. And this is an
image of the beast also.
Correct. The Vatican. Now, this is a
temple
because it has an altar in it.
Now, Protestantism removed all the
altars because we've had one complete
sacrifice. There's no need for a
sacrifice.
But under the Oxford Movement, which was
of course driven by the Jesuits,
the altar came back into the Anglican
Church.
And the mass is again a sacrifice.
That's a blasphemy.
Yeah. Because by one sacrifice he has
forever made perfect. So, this is a
temple, but it's not
just a Christian temple.
It's supposedly a Christian temple, but
actually it's a Masonic temple.
Yes.
And if you go inside, you will see on
the ceiling this depiction over here.
Martin, what is that? Uh
that is Freemasonry. This is Jesuitical,
the all-seeing eye and the compass and
set square. This is a Masonic temple.
So, when the king is coronated
Mhm.
and he walks in there with all his
regalia and all his little charms on his
chest, one of the most prominent ones
will be the Templar's sign.
Yeah, the Knights Templar, the the
Knights of Malta
cross.
Correct. He will wear that in the middle
and it'll also be on his crown.
Yeah.
And interestingly enough, Martin,
he has said that he wants to be the
defender of faith. That's a Masonic
concept. That's fratellituti,
bringing them all together. So, this is
the exoteric doctrine. This is a church,
a Protestant church. Esoteric doctrine,
this is an image of the beast and it is
Masonic.
Yeah, and it's worshipping Lucifer. In
other words, the true religion behind
the scenes is Lucifer.
So, we ask ourselves the question, who
is Babylon?
I think we have answered it and the
Bible is pretty clear
because if you go to Revelation chapter
17,
it talks about the woman riding the
beast, the church controlling the
political system. That's what it means.
And she has on her forehead mystery
Babylon,
the mother of all the harlots, right?
So, in other words, she is the main
mother and then she has daughters, Yes.
other churches, other organizations.
So, Babylon originally
was the ancient city and that religion
filtered down and the real harbinger of
that religion, Baal worship,
is today in its fullness found in Roman
Catholicism.
Mother and child worship, right?
Plus all the other doctrines that are
associated with it and the deification
of self. Seen that in the catechism.
The question we have to ask ourselves,
why is it fallen? Now, this message was
first given in
literal Babylon's time.
Yes.
And the message is given in antitypical
Babylon's time, right?
Yes. And the message was proclaimed in
1844.
Yes, at the close of the 2,300
years. Yes. So, the first angel's
message was to preach the everlasting
gospel.
The first angel was to say that the time
of judgment has come and that one must
worship God and give the glory to him.
Now, the message was
judgment has come and people believed
Christ was going to return.
But the churches rejected that message.
So, the next message was Babylon has
fallen, has fallen.
Now, Rome had always been fallen.
Yes.
So, which component had now fallen?
We'll come to that.
So, there's an announcement of the fall
of Babylon, but there is not yet a
general call out of Babylon.
And then we have to know what
constitutes the wine of Babylon and who
serves it and who drinks it. Now, we
know that Babylon is the ancient
religion disguised as a Christian
religion for the exoteric,
for the
but really it is a Luciferian religion
at its core.
Now, who is Babylon? We get a clue in 1
Peter 5:13, the church that is at
Babylon
elected together with you saluteth you
and so does Marcus my son. Now,
the church that is at Babylon, Babylon
never existed at this time in the world.
So, Peter was referring to Rome and
there's general consensus that he called
Rome Babylon.
Now, the Protestants,
did they again make it prominent that
Rome was Babylon? Yeah, for sure. All
right. So, let's go back in history,
Martin Luther.
He wrote the Babylonian Captivity of the
Church.
And in it he says that the Babylonian
Captivity of the Church, Martin Luther
set forth a reconsideration
of the sacramental Christian life that
centered on the word. His thesis is that
the papacy had distorted the sacraments
with its traditions and regulations,
transforming them into a system of
control and coercion.
So, he accused Rome of taking the heart
out of the gospel, negating the word and
putting traditions in its place and he
called that a Babylonian Captivity.
So, the Roman Church, according to him,
was Babylon.
Yes.
Now, Martin,
is it possible that Protestantism could
fall and become part of Babylon?
Yes, if they started compromising. Ah.
Grattan Guinness, who was a Church of
England theologian, in 1887
in his famous book Romanism and the
Reformation,
wrote about this occasion and he says,
"Rise up, Luther. Cry out concerning the
Babylonian Captivity of the Church. Burn
the papal bull. Rouse Germany, but you
shall have your match.
Satan shall bring forth his Loyola
and Loyola his Jesuits, subtle, learned,
saintly in garb and name, protean in
form, infinite in disguises, innumerable
scholars, teachers, theologians,
confessors of princes, politicians,
rhetoricians,
casuists, instruments keen,
unscrupulous, double-edged men fitted to
every sphere and every enterprise.
They shall swarm against the Church of
the Reformation,
each one wise in the wisdom and strong
in the strength which is are not from
above, but from beneath."
That's pretty straight talk by a
Protestant, right? Yeah, and this was
also in the 1800s. Yes.
Now, Martin, the Oxford Movement
actually gained this major victory over
Protestantism
and brought back Roman Catholicism and
its traditions and its sacrificial
system
into the church. And it was done in the
same principles that they told you it's
going to be done. There was an
exoteric
um explanation that Newman did.
And then afterwards, he became a
cardinal in the Catholic Church, so it
meant he was actually working esoteric.
Correct. And in 1844,
these manuscripts on which the modern
Bibles are based
were discovered, the Sinaiticus.
And Protestantism started swallowing the
Jesuitical line hook, line, and sinker.
Plus, they started to embrace the
counter-reformation
theology regarding the papacy. Futurism,
which today is evangelical mainstream
thinking,
and preterism, which is minority
Protestant thinking today. But both of
them taking you away.
Both of them Jesuitical.
So, when you embrace these teachings,
don't you fall? Yeah.
You fall because you're with Babylon.
All right.
So, let's go back to typical Babylon.
Jeremiah 51:7, "Babylon has been a
golden cup in the Lord's hand
and made all the earth drunken. The
nations have drunken of her wine,
therefore the nations are mad."
Mhm. That's a serious allegation.
So, in the time
of Jeremiah, who warned that Babylon was
going to take control of Jerusalem,
Mhm.
it was because the nations had gone mad
because they were practicing her
doctrines.
That's it. They were doing all these
filthy things.
They were so-called
worshipping
Yahweh, Mhm. while they were actually
worshipping Baal.
Yeah. So, they invoked the name of
Yahweh, but used the methodology and the
theology of Baal.
Mhm.
Isn't that what they're doing today?
the same today.
So, when Revelation 14:8 says, "And
there followed another angel saying,
'Babylon is fallen, is fallen.'" That's
the church-state union. "That great city
because she made all the nations drink
of the wine of the wrath of her
fornication." We have the same system.
All the nations are are drunk. Well,
people can just look around and ask
themselves, "Are the nations mad?"
They are mad. Look at the television,
they're mad. Yeah. They've definitely
gone mad.
Or Revelation 16:19,
"And the great city was divided into
three parts.
And the cities of the nations fell, and
the great Babylon came in remembrance
before God to give unto her the cup of
the wine of the fierceness of his
wrath." Accept their system
and you are an enemy of God.
Yeah. Yeah, you're part of Babylon. Is
that an important message?
Oh, well, it's got If you're going to be
part of it, you're going to fall with
it.
All right.
Now, Babylon has a number of components.
Revelation 16:13,
"And I saw three unclean spirits like
frogs
come out of the mouth of the dragon,
out of the mouth of the beast, and out
of the mouth of the false prophet."
So, here are three components of the
end-time Babylon. That's the final
complete Babylon.
So, you have the beast, which is
Catholicism.
You have the dragon, which according to
the scripture is Satan himself.
And you have the false prophet.
"For they are spirits of devils working
miracles, which go forth unto the kings
of the earth and of the whole world to
gather them to the
battle of that great day of God
Almighty."
Now, it says here, "Behold, I come as a
thief. Blessed is he that watches and
keepeth his garments, lest he walk naked
and they see his shame."
Martin, if you want to keep your
garment, you have to keep the garment of
Christ's righteousness.
Yes.
Otherwise, you will be naked like Adam
and Eve were, right?
"And he gathered them together into a
place." The word there is topos, Mhm.
"called in the Hebrew tongue
Armageddon."
So, this place can be literal,
but it can also be figurative. Now,
Babylon is antitypical. It's not a place
anymore.
No, because it used to be This is the
antitypical.
It has a metaphorical meaning, which
means mindset.
Mhm.
"Gathered together into the same
mindset, they wondered with an O
after the beast. They received the same
mindset. They'd been indoctrinated."
And if you accept this, then he will
come to you as a thief.
You will not expect him. Yeah.
But 1 Thessalonians 5:4 says, "But ye
brethren are not in darkness that that
day should overtake you as a thief."
Who was he referring?
Brethren. Yes.
this like you mentioned before, not
neighbor. Here he's speaking to the
brethren. They You won't be overtaken if
you If If If you trust in this word,
Martin, you need not be deceived. That's
it. But you have to watch.
You have to study the circumstances. You
cannot drink in every word that comes
out of the mouth of Babylon.
No.
Jesus also said, when they asked him,
"When will the end come and how will we
know and what will the signs be?" He
said the first words like you mentioned
before,
"Be careful that you are not deceived."
Correct.
So, Martin, there were three components.
Now, the dragon and the beast have
always been in partnership.
Mhm.
How do we know that? Well, Revelation
13:2 says, "And the beast
which I saw was like unto a leopard, and
his feet were as the feet of a bear, and
his mouth as the mouth of a lion." So,
here we have the conglomerate beast of
Daniel chapter 7, putting all those
ideologies of all those kingdoms
together.
"And the dragon gave him his power and
his seat and great authority." So, the
dragon and the beast were always
together.
So, all dragon religions where the
spirit world is invoked,
that would be any religion out there
that invokes spirit beings.
Yeah. That's shamanism or any one of the
other religions.
They have dragon power,
but the beast gets a seat
and great authority.
We talk about the bishop's seat, and the
seat of the bishop of Rome is in Rome.
That is the city, and when he speaks, he
speaks from his seat. He speaks ex
cathedra infallibly.
"And they worshipped the dragon, which
gave power unto the beast, and they
worshipped the beast saying, 'Who is
like unto the beast?'" So, if you're in
the system, Martin, you're a Luciferian.
You're worshipping the dragon. You're
worshipping the devil.
Just like Blavatsky said.
Yeah. And Masons do exactly the same.
Mhm.
And those that do not know about it
haven't studied it deeply enough. That's
unfortunate, but it's true. 1
Corinthians 10:20 says, "But I say that
the things which the Gentiles sacrifice,
they sacrifice to devils and not to God.
And I would not that you should have
fellowship with devils." That's putting
it pretty plainly.
You see, that's the same that you just
said. You don't have the truth, you're
worshipping devils.
"You cannot drink the cup of the Lord
and the cup of devils. You cannot be
partakers of the Lord's table and of the
table of devils. You must make a
choice." You see, but they do this. They
do this.
They have at um but I'll partake of the
Lord's table and of the table of the
devils because they have this whole
esoteric and eso-exoteric thing going
on.
All right. 1 Timothy 4:1,
"Now, the spirit speaketh expressly that
in the latter times some shall depart
from the faith, giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils."
So, in the latter times, Martin, we're
talking about this. In 1844, the message
went out, "Babylon is fallen."
Mhm. Is it possible that some had
actually followed seducing spirits and
doctrines of devils
Yeah. and became ecumenical?
Revelation 16:14, "For they are the
spirits of devils working miracles,
which go forth unto the kings of the
earth and of the whole world to gather
them to the battle of that great day of
God Almighty." To that mindset, that
topos,
Mhm.
where you have to make a decision. Am I
going to run with this Fratelli Tutti,
or am I going to run with what the Bible
says? Yeah.
If I run with what the Bible says, do I
become the enemy of the system?
Yes, you do.
You stand out like a sore thumb.
Yep.
You are You are against peace and
goodwill? You are. You are against the
common good, Martin?
Oh, you have to get taken out.
All right.
Revelation 9:20,
"And the rest of the men which were not
killed by these plagues." Talking about
the last seven plagues.
"Yet repented not of the works of their
hands, that they should not worship
devils
and idols of gold and silver and brass
and stone and of wood, which neither can
see, nor hear, nor walk." Do we have
them in all the religious systems of the
world except pure Protestantism? Yeah.
Yes. We have idols of wood and stone all
over in all the religious systems. And
idols of gold.
But Martin, they're worshipping devils.
devils. That's what the Bible says.
So, let's ask a question. What
constitutes the wine of Babylon? Who
serves it and who drinks it?
The nations have gone mad.
Did Protestantism receive a message from
God
via the reformers
that they had to break with the
Babylonian system of Rome? Definitely.
Yes, and they had time, a little less
than 500 years until 1844 to make a
decision. Right.
So, Martin, if they knew the truth
and now they embraced the lie, do they
then fall? Yes. So, Babylon has fallen.
Didn't apply to Rome, which was already
fallen. It didn't apply to the dragon,
who had fallen already in heaven.
Mhm.
It applies to Protestantism.
Yeah. Which now joined in and also fell.
Matthew 9:17, neither do men put new
wine into old bottles, else the bottles
break and the wine runneth out and the
bottles perish.
But they put new wine into new bottles
and both are preserved. If you want to
have new wine, the doctrine of salvation
in Christ you have to become a new
person. You must be born again. Cleanse.
Not You cannot have an old wineskin with
all these new doctrines. So, if you want
to stick to your traditions and you want
to stick to all of this nonsense, this
exoteric stuff that have been fed to you
Martin
you can't do it. You are worshipping on
the wrong side.
Now, two great lies stand out as wine.
Mhm.
And these two lies will unify humanity
against against the gospel.
Yes. And they are the immortality of the
soul and Sunday worship.
Now we're going to deal with them in
some detail. We're not going to deal
with the Sunday worship issue in any
detail at all in this lecture.
But we're going to deal with the
immortality of the soul
a little bit.
Yeah. The reason we're not dealing with
the Sunday one is because that forms
part of the third angel's message, which
is on its way. Correct. Through the two
great errors
the immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness, Satan will bring the people
under his deceptions. In other words,
they will drink the wine.
While the former lays the foundation for
spiritualism, the latter creates a bond
of sympathy with Rome.
The Protestants of the United States
will be foremost in stretching their
hands across the gulf to grasp the hand
of spiritualism.
They will reach over the abyss to clasp
the hands of the Roman power and under
the influence of this threefold union
this country will follow in the steps of
Rome in trampling on the rights of
conscience. This comes from the great
controversy.
Protestantism will grab the hand of
spiritualism.
And they will grab the hand of Rome.
And then the dragon component will be in
Protestantism, spiritualism.
The beast component will be controlling
them. Mhm. And they will be a false
prophet. Yeah. All three.
words, they will teach lies. Now, when
literal Babylon attacked the church, did
Jeremiah warn against false prophets?
Yes.
So, Jeremiah was standing for the truth
Mhm. and he warned against the false
prophets in his own system.
Yeah. He was standing in the gate.
Think about that.
Let's have a look at ecumenism.
This comes from the New World
Encyclopedia.
The contemporary ecumenical movement for
Protestants is often said to have
started with the 1910 Edinburgh
Missionary Conference. So, this is for
Protestants. When did they join the
ecumenical movement?
However, this conference would not have
been possible without the pioneering
ecumenical work of the Christian youth
movements. The Young Men's Christian
Association founded in 1844.
The Young Women's Christian Association
founded just a few years later in 1855.
The World Student Christian Federation
in 1895
led by Methodist layman John R. Mott,
former YMCA staff. And in 1910, the
general secretary of the WCF, the World
Mission Conference, marked the largest
Protestant gathering to that time. Prior
to this, it was only individuals.
So, a starting date for the ecumenical
movement as far as Protestants is
concerned is 1844. Yeah.
They started to imbibe the wine.
So, does that qualify them for a fallen
state? Definitely, because it fits right
into the when the message went out,
Babylon is fallen, is fallen. 1844.
So, Catholics and Lutherans confirm
commitment to communion. The Pontifical
Council for Promoting Christian Unity
and the Lutheran World Federation
underscore their commitment to walk
together on their common journey from
conflict to communion.
What about the Babylonian captivity of
the church?
After taking their hands and say,
"Handcuff us again. We want to be in the
Babylonian
We want to be in the
community?" Aren't they then Babylon?
Yes. They have become Babylon. They have
fallen. They have fallen. They're going
back into Babylonian captivity. The
Bible says, "Get out."
Yeah.
So, let's ask some Protestants that were
still awake.
This is 1946. This is Moody Press.
Martin, 1946, it's quite a while back,
right?
The reformers regarded the Holy
Scriptures as the sole rule of faith and
practice and the sons of the reformers
throw the sole rule out of the window.
Torn to shreds by the deft impious hands
of the critic.
Mhm.
Does that qualify them for becoming
Babylon? Then you move over to the
Babylonian city. With the Bible goes the
God of the Bible. And when we charge
Rome with literal idolatry for her
veneration of images, relics and so
forth, she comes back with an accusation
of intellectual idolatry.
And that Protestantism having rejected
the God of revelation
has created a new God, the product of
apostate thinking.
So, here you have higher criticism.
Yeah.
Which is actually steered by Jesuits in
the background.
Exactly. It's part of the exoteric part
movement.
have to change the entire religion in
order to do this.
Rome is not afraid of modernism. It is a
fruitful fishing pool because the human
heart cannot be satisfied with the
vague, vaporous uncertainties of
modernism. Rome addresses herself to
those who are under the influence of
that emasculated brand of Protestantism
and offers the authority of the church
founded by Jesus Christ in place of the
bewildering uncertainties of
indifferentism.
Martin they accept the authority of
Rome. It has never moved. They go back
to the mother. So, she's the mother of
harlots.
Yes. Because the harlots have embraced
idolatry and come back to her. Come back
and be part of Babylon again. Now, we
have no king but Jesus Mhm. said the
Protestant reformers in Scotland.
Now they're shouting, "We have no king
but the pope." The Caesar.
Let's go to the time 1844.
They rejected the literal coming of
Christ. And they were a little bit
afraid and many of them thought it might
happen, but when it finally didn't
happen and he didn't come in 1844, they
were so relieved. They were so happy.
Now, what did Luther say about the book
of Daniel?
He writes, "Therefore, we bid that all
earnest Christians read the book of
Daniel, to whom it will be a consolation
and a great prophet in these last
miserable times.
And when these things begin to pass look
up and lift up your head because your
redemption is at hand. For the same
reason we find in Daniel that all the
dreams and visions are fearful they
might be and always enjoy and gladness
with the coming of Christ and his
kingdom.
Yay, for that chief article of faith,
the coming of Christ these visions were
given, explained and recorded."
Based on the book of Daniel, they began
to understand the book of Revelation.
Yes. In Luther's time.
In Luther's time and they were very
clear as to who the beasts were in the
book of Daniel and how that the beast in
Revelation chapter 13 was a conglomerate
of those political religious systems.
They were absolutely crystal clear. By
the time you get to 1844, they had drunk
so much wine
Yeah. that they forgot that doctrine.
That's why we had to have the first
angel message to wake them up again.
To wake them up. And the coming of
Christ was the message. And this is the
chief article, he's coming again. Did
Luther believe it? Yes. Did they believe
it after all those years? I No. They had
to be woken up again. No. In fact, they
threw the people out of the churches
that actually believed it.
Luther and the second coming. In 1538,
he wrote in commenting on the prevalent
godlessness, Luther said, "I hope that
day is not far off and we shall still
see it." Did he have an expectation?
Yes, he was longing for it.
He writes, "I hope the last day will not
tarry over 100 years because God's word
will be taken away again and a great
darkness will come for scarcity of
ministers of the word." Was his
prediction? Yeah, that's prophetic.
He was speaking prophetically. He didn't
even know it because that's exactly what
happened.
It was almost 400 years.
God is so patient. He gives people the
truth and they reject it. They go back
to Rome and they become part of Babylon.
Babylon is fallen is fallen.
Here's another one. "Oh Christ my Lord,
look down upon us and bring upon us thy
day of judgment and destroy the brood of
Satan in Rome."
Did the Protestants in 1844 still shout
that, Martin?
No.
Would they shout it today? No. No, no.
There sits the man of whom the Apostle
Paul wrote in 2 Thessalonians chapter 2
that he will oppose and exalt himself
above all that is called God, that man
of sin, the son of perdition. What else
is papal power but sin and corruption?
It leads souls to destruction under
thine own name, oh Lord. I hope that day
of judgment is soon to dawn.
Things can and will not become worse
than they are at this time. Man, have I
got news for him. Well, no. Yeah, I
think he will he might rewrite that if
he's know knows what's going on.
The papal see is practicing iniquity to
its heights. He suppresses the law of
God
and exalts his commandments above the
commandments of God, Martin. Martin?
Wouldn't you want to be a Luther at this
time? You've got the right first name.
Yeah, I know.
Huh?
Do they still believe this? No,
unfortunately.
they have become part of Babylon.
Yes.
So, let's have a look at the doctrine of
the literal return of Christ. It was
rejected in 1844 and this led to a
spiritualization
of the doctrine of Christ.
This is what I'm writing. Mhm.
And this opened the floodgates for
doctrines of demons to enter the
churches. Isn't that a terrible
statement to make? It is.
Unless it's true.
So, 2 Corinthians 11
warns against this thing.
For if he that cometh preaches another
Jesus whom we have not preached,
is that possible?
Yeah, that's what we seeing. Or you
receive another spirit.
Can Protestantism receive another
spirit? It can. It did. Which you have
not received or another gospel
which you have not accepted, you might
well bear with them.
They're very apt to absorb false
doctrine.
I marvel that you are so soon removed
from him that called you unto the grace
of Christ unto another gospel which is
not another but there be some that
trouble you and would pervert the gospel
of Christ. This happened in Paul's day.
How much more so will it happen
when Babylon has fallen?
Be not deceived.
Many will depart from the faith giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of devils. This is a letter 263.
And Martin, it has happened. It's
quoting the Bible. We have now before us
the alpha of this danger. The omega will
be of a most startling nature. Can it
even become worse even within
the realms of God's people? Yes.
Because when Babylonian
tentacles start creeping in
then you start losing or compromising
and you start moving slowly back to
Babylon. Martin, what is an Adventist?
He's looking forward to the soon coming
of Christ. All right. Now, spiritualism
spiritualizes it away.
So, let's see how they do that. Let's
listen to Blavatsky.
Blavatsky about the second coming. The
coming of Christ means the presence of
Christos in a regenerated world and not
at all the actual coming in body of
Christ Jesus.
Gone is a literal coming, right? This is
spiritism.
This is occultism. This is masonry.
This is esoteric doctrine.
Christ, the true esoteric savior, is no
man but the divine principle in every
human being. This is devil language.
That's it.
He who strives to resurrect the spirit
crucified in him by his own terrestrial
passions and buried deep in the
sepulcher of his sinful flesh, he who
has the strength to roll back the stone
of matter from the door of his own inner
sanctuary, he has the risen Christ in
him.
Esoteric doctrine, diseased,
satanic,
demonic, doctrines of devils. This is
what it is.
The most revered prophet of the new age.
And she
was
the influencer of Alice A. Bailey. Alice
A. Bailey in the United Nations.
All of this is infiltrated everywhere.
It's in society. It's in everything, in
churches. All right. So, the deification
of self is our doctrine. Let's make sure
again. The Vatican official foundational
starting point is man.
Rome states in its Vatican II documents.
This comes from 1962, Martin.
It is man himself who must be saved. It
is mankind that must be renewed. It is
man therefore is the key to this
discussion. Man considered whole and
entire with body, soul, heart,
conscience, mind, and will. This is the
reason why the sacred synod, Vatican II,
in proclaiming the noble destiny of man
and affirming an element of the divine
in him offers to cooperate unreservedly
with mankind in fostering a sense of
brotherhood to correspond to this
destiny of theirs.
Is that evil or not?
Blavatsky could just as well have
written this.
Absolutely.
This is fratellituti. Yeah. This is
Christian. And that is why Pope Francis,
a Jesuit, was chosen to push the agenda.
It is the doctrine of devils.
Because he knows the esoteric meaning of
everything. And if you take part in
this, Martin, then you're worshipping
devils.
You're worshipping devils.
Here is Alfred H. Paul's book, 17
reasons why I left the tongues movement.
Now, remember that the Bible says you
receive another Jesus. Yeah.
In other words, they're actually saying
you receive a Jesus that never died for
you because you can become one yourself.
Yeah.
And you receive another spirit. Mhm.
Now, the tongues movement is very strong
in the Protestant world. You were part
of that before you came out of Babylon.
Yeah.
I wish that I were wrong.
But all signs at the present indicate
that the charismatic movement could be
the common denominator for a worldwide
ecumenical organization or church.
It's gluing everyone together, Martin.
Especially
the one that was not very easy to do and
that was Rome and Protestantism.
All right. Now, when the when the Lord
separated the languages
and when he called his church out to be
separate and not to be part of anything,
is that ecumenical or anti-ecumenical?
It's anti-ecumenical.
Okay. So, the tongues movement
pushes you towards ecumenism.
Yes. What spirit is it then? Is it the
spirit of the Lord?
Is he fighting against himself?
No.
Because Hinduism speaks in tongues.
Shamanism speaks in tongues.
And uh Satanists speak in tongues.
Huh? Of course. Now, you've got
Catholics speaking tongues. You got
evangelicals speaking in tongues. Like
this guy says, it's a common denominator
to glue them together. But the true
tongues were literal languages te idiota
dialecto in their own mother tongue.
Martin, is this spirit working contrary
to the spirit of God?
100% against it.
And is the spirit becoming the norm
other than the word?
It's the spirit
the spirit experience.
Okay.
So, in the past, all attempts to bring
about ecumenicity on the basis of faith,
belief, or doctrine have failed.
But in the charismatic movement, unity
is attained not by the unanimity of
doctrine
but on the basis of a common religious
experience.
Now, Martin, can you now understand why
a queen or a king can knight
a religious figure
and one who openly embraces Satanists
like many of these rock stars that are
knighted and become sir? So, now it
makes sense because how else can you Is
yin yang? Yeah.
Okay.
To them largely, doctrine is not the
important thing, but the experience is.
So, it is not surprising that in
charismatic circles, people of many
denominational backgrounds and doctrines
can all worship and fellowship together.
Not because they agree on doctrine, but
because they agree on a common religious
experience.
This is a very dangerous trend. Why?
Because setting truth aside in order to
have unity will ultimately put the one
who is the truth, the Lord Jesus outside
of the movement.
And that is what's happening. Babylon,
did it fall? Yes. Did the floodgates
open to take the hand of spiritism?
Yes. Because this is spiritism.
Spiritism, and they use one of the
powerful tools music to get this done.
And music uses hypnotism by putting you
into an altered state of consciousness.
So, it's back to spirit- spiritism.
Martin, this is this is very heavy
discussion. I realize this, but how far
can it go?
Luther and Tyndale on death. Many
believe the soul is immortal and remains
conscious apart from the body after
death, but early reformers Martin Luther
and William Tyndale recognized what the
Bible teaches about this.
That those who have died have no
awareness while awaiting a future
resurrection.
So, once you start believing that you
can talk to the deceased, you are where
Babylon is.
Because Rome tells you to invoke Mary
and the saints. They are deceased. They
know nothing. They are dead. They are
asleep.
So, what here now
can talk to all of these as well. You
you can talk to them. Or, if you
actually believe that you go either to
hell or to heaven right after death, you
sitting with the same problem. So,
Martin Luther and Tyndale, both of them
gave us the Bible in the common tongue.
Martin Luther in German, Tyndale in
English.
Right? That's They believed in soul
sleep. They translated the Bible. They
had to mull over every word. This was
their conviction.
Not only they, but John Frith believed
it. John Milton.
He was the English poet, polemicist, man
of letters, and civil servant
Commonwealth of England
under its Council of State and later
under Cromwell. He wrote at a time of
religious flux and political upheaval
and is best known for his epic poem
Paradise Lost.
Written in blank verse.
He believed in soul sleep.
Wycliffe.
Mhm. The morning star of the
Reformation. Morey suggests that
Wycliffe and Tyndale taught the doctrine
of soul sleep as the answer to the
Catholic teaching of purgatory and
masses for the dead. And it makes sense
because
according to the Catholic system uh
teaching
the devil was right when he told Eve,
"You will surely not die." Correct.
Solomon, this is what Martin Luther
wrote. Solomon judges that the dead are
asleep. This is written in old English,
so it's not misspelled.
And feel nothing at all.
For the dead lie there a compting, in
other words, cognatizing, neither days
nor years.
But when they are awoken, they shall
seem to have slept scarce 1 minute.
That's what Martin Luther believed.
Now, today you can have a divine
connection in your pocket.
You can get an app and discover a new
interactive way to engage with your
faith through the text with Jesus.
And he will answer you.
And the way in which he writes, Martin,
is exactly the same way in which the
esoteric writes.
I used to be very involved in the New
Age movement.
And he would write, "My dear ones, my
enlightened ones,
my loved ones, my disciples." That's how
he would write. And this is how the
answers here are also given. It is
nauseating to me. But now you can
communicate with Jesus. But the reason
it's nauseating to you is because you
understand the esoteric
um hidden nuances of this. Correct. Now,
Jesus is not sleeping. He is
resurrected. Don't get me wrong.
people that will read it exoterically
will probably not see it in the same
way. But once you've gone through this
lecture, hopefully, you can also start
seeing, "Wait, this is not according to
how the the biblical Jesus will talk."
Correct.
So, here's another example. The New York
Post controversial new AI app allows you
to text with Jesus and Satan.
That's interesting. All right.
It's not every day that the spiritual
realm intersects with smartphone texts,
but in an era of chatbots and AI, even
the biblical figures aren't immune.
Welcome to the world of text with Jesus.
Where you're just a tap away from a
conversation with the holy and for a
price, the not so holy.
Deepening faith through text with Jesus.
For those longing for a more personal
connection to their faith, this app
might be the digital salvation they are
seeking. Designed with devoted
Christians in mind, Text with Jesus
promises interaction with figures like
Jesus, Mary, Joseph, Peter, and Matthew.
Now,
Mary, Joseph, Peter, and Matthew,
according to the scripture, are what?
Asleep. Asleep. They know nothing. They
will awake at the resurrection.
You are speaking, if they answer,
esoterically. You're getting doctrines
of devils. Yes. So, this is spiritism on
steroids.
Because Loyola's exercises tells you to
put yourself into a situation and listen
to what Mary or Joseph has to say to
you. Now, this is just one app. There
are apps now that enable you to speak to
your deceased loved ones.
So, is he pushing the immortality of the
soul issue?
Completely. Is it uniting the various
religions because they all believe
exactly the same? Yes. Don't they invoke
the dead?
That is necromancy. It is forbidden by
God because you are speaking to demons.
And just to put it out there, that tells
you how dangerous it is if you look at
Hollywood productions. Like for
instance, even
children's
movies
are full of necromancing and magic and
all the speaking to to to to deceased.
Well, we could go on forever and ever
speaking about the sins of Babylon.
But just for interest's sake, I'm just
going to briefly mention here the
treasury of merit
on which indulgences were based.
So, this treasure that the church has
where it can dish out or the Pope can
dish out merit for those that lack some.
This treasury includes as well the
prayers and good works of the Blessed
Virgin Mary. They are truly immense,
unfathomable, and even pristine in their
value before God. In the treasury, too,
are the prayers and good works of all
the saints.
They're all dead.
They know nothing. So, this is
necromancy. This is
the doctrine of devils. It's Babylon.
So, as part of a greater effort to use
social media to connect with the
Catholics worldwide, the Pope will start
relieving punishment for your sins via
social media.
Are we not going from the ridiculous to
the sublime?
Shouldn't Protestantism realize that
they're dealing with Babylon?
Of
Of course. And you have to know who
Babylon is. All right. If you know that
the papacy
is the beast component of Babylon and
that he is in cahoots with the dragon
and now he's
dishing out relief from your punishment
via an app.
you can WhatsApp him and there you go.
Shouldn't you say, "What am I doing in
an ecumenical council with these people?
Am I not in cahoots with the doctrines
of devils?" This will pull you into
Babylon again if you mingle with this.
Correct. Vatican offers time off
purgatory to follow
uh to followers of Pope Francis's
tweets.
So, you can relieve your punishment,
which doesn't exist because there is no
purgatory in the scriptures anyway.
But you just follow his tweets.
Isn't Isn't this demonic? Yes, it's
doctrines of devils. There are three
ways of obtaining these indulgences. You
can make a pilgrimage to the shrine. Is
that salvation by works?
Yes. That's uh the same as Babylon
Bible. Or pray before any statue of Our
Lady of Fatima. Is that idolatry?
Isn't that forbidden by the second
commandment, which they have removed
from their catechism?
And the third way
is to obtain a plenary indulgence. It
applies to people because of age,
illness, or other serious cause are
unable to get around. So, all you have
to do is say, "I want to do it, but I
can't." And you'll also get it.
Is this idolatry? Is this Babylonian?
Babylonian doctrine that is that's
So, the announcement, this isn't again
what I wrote. The announcement of the
fall of Babylon is repeated by the angel
of Revelation 18. We've just looked at
the angel of Revelation 14.
The second angel.
angel. Why Babylon has fallen. We've
identified Babylon.
We saw that the component that fell in
1844 was Protestantism.
And it's hooked into the system and it's
part of Babylon now.
Yeah.
So, what comes out of the mouth of the
dragon, the dragon religions, what comes
out of the mouth of Catholicism
is
exoteric doctrine, while they actually
believe esoteric doctrine.
And what comes out of the mouth of the
false prophet is no better than what
they were. Nothing. Because they've
become part of them.
And they have to hide their distinctive
belief in Jesus Christ not to offend
Mhm. those that don't believe that he's
the way, the truth, and the life.
So, you'll hear the whole time them
speaking of Jesus Christ. And but it's
an esoteric Christ. Exactly. When
they're teach making you think it's an
esoteric Christ.
So, the scripture in Revelation 18, this
scripture points forward to a time when
the announcement of the fall of Babylon
is made by the second angel of
Revelation is to be repeated with the
additional mention of the corruptions
which have entered the various
organizations that constitute Babylon
since that message was first given in
the summer of 1844.
That's when ecumenism started.
Yeah.
That's when evolution theory went into
the world.
These announcements uniting with the
third angel's message constitute the
final warning to be given to the
inhabitants of the earth. But we're not
there yet. We still have to do a lecture
on this.
That's it. So, our Babylon talk now was
just an introduction.
This is an introduction because now we
will move over
to the more pointed
parts of Babylon.
But before we get to Revelation 18, we
first have to do the third angel.
Yes.
So, in our next discussion we'll have to
speak about the importance of the third
angel's message. I hope that the viewers
will understand
what Babylon is.
I hope they will understand, Martin, why
it is important to recognize what
Babylon stands for
and that you cannot be associated with
it. No, because it's fallen. Fallen,
you're going to fall together with it if
you get correct. And if you are in a
system or a component
of that system, you have to separate
yourself.
But we'll come to that. Before the
separation, the final separation will
take place.
There first has to be a third angel.
Yeah.
Let's wait for that for next time. Let's
pray.
Heavenly Father, the sad story of the
fall of Babylon.
The dragon, the beast,
and then sadly
the false prophet.
Lord, help us not to be part of
Babylonian systems,
but to embrace the truth
because you are the way, the truth, and
the life. In Jesus' name, amen.
Amen.